hey welcome to the monitor I am senior
editor Peter Rubin and first up this
week we're going to talk about an album
that's out from the 1n only LP LP
Brooklyn rapper one third of the great
underground hip hop group company flow
from the late 90s been a solo artist and
producer for some time now last week he
actually produced the entirety of killer
mike's new album which is also great but
LP solo album cancer for cure dropped
yesterday by all means pick it up we had
his first single I guess it was drones
over Brooklyn on wired late last year
but now the entire album is out and it's
every bit as dystopian and miserable as
well as all his best stuff is no one
loves rapping about a failed police
state more than LP and he does it in
fine fashion future doesn't look bright
according to him of course it looks
bright for him he's been successful for
how long now but definitely worth it by
all means pick it up or stream it on
Spotify which I assume it's on because
everything is on Spotify except for Pink
Floyd but you know now we're going to go
to our correspondent in the field who's
going to talk to you a little bit about
a new TV show that's just starting up
the need to get up on ok so this is a
really good week for comedy jeez I'm
sorry and Hannibal Buress both have
stand-up specials on Comedy Central that
started over the weekend and there's
going to be re running for months wall
to wall to wall to wall all the walls
you're gonna have no problem finding and
seeing it but there's also another show
a comedy show that you need to see it
started on Sunday night and it's on it
like 1230 and it's really hard to find
out about called Eric Andre show and
it's on adult swim and it is a talk show
kind of but the sidekick is Hannibal
Buress and Eric Andre in the comic is
the host and it's I don't even know how
to describe it the first show has George
Clooney as a guest except it's not
actually George Clooney and then the
other guest is Dolph Lundgren but it
actually is Dolph Lundgren who knows how
they got Dolph Lundgren to be on the
show because it is the weirdest most
sublimely bizarre glorious thing I've
ever seen wouldn't do justice to it
I tried to describe it so I'm just going
to tell you go watch it if i can get
reception here in this cabin to watch it
you have no excuse back to you Peter
okay movies a couple things coming out
this weekend but here's what's going to
happen I am going to see men in black 3
for 2 reasons one is because josh brolin
and Tommy Lee Jones are kind of morphing
into this weird island of dr. Moreau
version of george w bush which i find
vastly entertaining but the second
reason is because i can't handle the
movie that i actually really want to see
this weekend which is the Chernoble
diaries here we go it's written by oren
peli who of course was behind paranormal
activity and paranormal activity 3
notable exception being paranormal
activity two but no one really likes to
talk about that one at any rate he's on
board with a different franchise
direction it's about what wouldn't you
know it a group of crazy kids that goes
to a nuclear wasteland and finds things
they weren't expecting comes up with
these things but chernobyl Diaries gets
my haiku review of the weak nuclear
mutants paranormal director too scary
for me that's it I wish I could see it
but I can't I need to start wetting the
bed when I'm in my 30s it's a little
unseemly so that's it for this week's
installment of the monitor will be back
next week with all kinds of pop culture
goodness stuff in your brain as always
until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you